money is not evil and money is not
everything money is a tool and it's a
very valuable tool and a very important
tool and something that everybody needs
to figure out that if you actually want
to serve you need to figure out how to
make money when people ask what's the
secret to health a lot of people default
to diet and sleep my answer the secret
to health is actually loving the work
that you're doing if you woke up every
day and felt like I love what I'm about
to do today I'm going to go serve
somebody and it's not that sleep's not
important cuz it is and diet's not
important but it is but I think there's
a lot of people who are in great
physical shape hate their lives if you
really love the work that you're doing I
think that's a secret to a long healthy
happy life and everything flows from
there an is part of our move makers
program and part of that we're doing
this uh Instagram live together so
what's on your mind how can I help I
want to talk about believe and beliefs
what one got you going on belief and um
what is it all about for you wow what a
what an opening so I think lack of
belief is the world's biggest problem
you know anytime that we want to make a
shift in our lives and we want to grow
we want to become somebody new we want
to hit our goals uh it's not really a
how question it it's a often a belief
question it's like we could get all the
strategies of what we're supposed to do
but we don't believe in ourselves enough
to go take that next step and every
major growth I've seen in my life came
on the other side of me believing myself
a little bit more to do something bigger
Boulder uh you know what does an
evolution of Evan carmichel look like
and over the years uh I've come to
realize that believe is my one word I go
through a process with people to figure
out what's your most important core
value so mine is believe I think
everybody has one and that's the thing
that you need to continue to work on but
it's also the gift that you want to give
to the world so
my you know ultimate ambition is to help
people believe in themselves more
and I don't have all the answers of how
to do it I'm I'm constantly learning and
constantly improving and I see our
journey as we're taking steps up a
mountain and every time we take another
step we reach back to try to help
somebody else get to our level uh the
way I'm trying to solve it right now is
content at scale so I think if if I can
put out positive content that helps
people believe in themselves more that
could be part of somebody's daily
routine uh I think that starts to shift
people's belief forward uh because I
need it myself like I still make videos
for me because I want to be around Oprah
and my angelu and Steve Jobs and every
time I hear them speak it makes me
believe in myself a little bit more to
take the next step um and I think it's a
daily thing where when we wake up at
least for me I don't wake up super like
I'm gonna TIG on the world let's go
Andre like I don't wake up like that I
wake up and and I need I need the I need
the the reminder because no matter how
great today is I'm waking up tomorrow
and I still need that reminder to
believe myself a little bit more and I
get that through the content that I put
up so it started with just that content
then it became helping people who were
big names in the space get their content
out to the world and uh you know
yesterday we released a video on the
channel uh from Jim ran it was the last
video interview that Jim ran ever did
and we got the uh permission to put it
up on our Channel and so I want to help
people you know either either who are
currently living legends or past Legends
expose the content as well as programs
like Movie Makers where I'm training the
Next Generation to get their message out
because people will learn from you Andre
in a way where they won't learn from me
your story your background your life
experiences they'll look at me and say I
can't connect to that guy but I connect
to you that's how I'm trying to solve it
uh I don't have all the answers but you
know you know we've made some pretty
significant steps over the past number
of years and if you've got any ideas or
tips or strategies I'm all leers too
because again I think lack of belief is
the world's number one problem we all
want to serve and help and give and
we're all mentors to other people and
some you know movement makers we want to
have a big impact build the movement
impact at scale but even if even if
we're not doing that yet uh just the
people around us the people closest to
us your words your actions um what
you're doing every day that has an
impact on people and you get to choose
if that's a positive one or negative one
I think money is an interesting belief I
think I don't think many people grow up
with a healthy belief around money uh
some people believe that money is
everything and you know the next person
who walks in that's my that's that
person's my next bag or my next shoes or
my next mortgage payment or and you're
just treating people like uh they're
your next payday uh and some people
think that money is the opposite they
think money is the root of all evil
right you a lot of people are T money is
the root of all evil and that's not the
actual quote it's the love of money is
the root of all evil not that money is
the root of all people missed that
little extra bit at the beginning uh but
and it's neither money is not evil and
money is not everything money is a tool
and it's a very valuable tool and a very
important tool and something that um
everybody needs to figure out that if
you actually want to serve you need to
figure fig how to make money you know
money I like to say money has to be in
your top five you just can't be number
one you know if money is number one
you'll never go off and do anything
significant or huge or and feel great
about yourself but if money is like
number a thousand then you're constantly
working evenings and weekends on your
mission instead of actually doing you
know the thing that you could be paid to
do and build a team like me with a team
of 42 people I could do so much more
than if it was me only part-time and
evenings and weekends trying to figure
my thing out because I'm serving but
just not at scale and so the ability to
figure out how to make money I think is
really important it just can't be number
one number one is your purpose number
one is the mission that you're on to try
to hopefully change the world those are
the people that uh you know I love
talking to the most absolutely um the
way we um utilize service and what we do
you me Les Brown Oprah any else we have
a deep down inside a core love and a
purpose for what we do we want to see
people to succeed in whatever they're
trying to succeed in but you know what
for me it's the suffering that I went
through in my life that I want to see
people break the suffering patterns in
their lives and how do they do that they
have to understand that a lot of the
things that we go through Evan is caused
by ourselves we might not know that but
we do and that's when I talk about the
body the spirit and the Soul
connectively um you have to understand
that they they work hand in hand pretty
much and if you uh focus on just your
body getting your body physically Fit
and Well and things of that nature but
then you forsake your emotions or your
mindset or the thoughts that are coming
up then you're going to miss some part
of bringing yourself to wholeness and so
that's what I try very hard to focus on
is to helping people people to become
whole individuals their authentic selves
who they've been created to be what are
your thoughts on that yeah I have a
maybe controversial view on this because
I've talked about this on a few podcasts
like really that's your answer uh when
people ask like what's the what's the
secret to uh health and I think a lot
lot of people default to diet and sleep
and you know a lot of the typical things
but for at least for me my answer this
secret to health is actually loving the
work that you're doing I think if you
woke up every day and felt like I love
what I'm about to do today I'm gonna go
serve somebody and it's not that sleep's
not important because it is and diet's
not important what it is but I think
there's a lot of people who are in great
physical shape or who have the perfect
you know sleep routine or the perfect
diet who who hate their lives yeah where
I think if you actually just if you
really love the work that you're
I think that's a secret to a long
healthy happy life and everything flows
from there and so connecting to your
purpose understanding how you can serve
that your purpose comes from your pain
you know you mentioned it that you want
to help other people who basically are
struggling with the same thing that you
struggled with and that's the best like
when you find somebody who's basically
the same as you but you're just a little
bit further along on the journey and you
struggled and you suffered and you you
know almost exhausted all the options
then you finally found the path and you
can shortcut that path for somebody else
it's the best feeling ever you know like
that thing that took you 10 years to
figure out they're now figuring it out
in a month because they met you um
absolutely and so that's why I'm so
passionate getting the message out and
training other people uh in Movie Makers
and individuals like yourself because if
you got your story out there and then
that changes somebody's life and then
that one becomes 10 becomes 100 becomes
a thousand becomes 10,000 it just
continues to grow because you had the
courage to get up and share your story
absolutely I was just thinking about
what you said just now and um it
resonated with my heart is that you know
passion and purpose and when I think
about because I have a very creative
mind I'm also a person that loves to
create um party plan or like decorations
and things of that nature and I don't
know if you understand or notice this
about yourself but for me when I get in
this what is called a Zone and I call it
my spiritual Zone time will fly when I'm
doing exactly what I'm passionate about
doing and I'm in my purpose and I'm
flowing and it just goes it comes so
easy for me to do and and um that
creativity just flourishes and I think
that that that's what happens with all
of us when we're doing exactly what
we've been purposed to do and we have
passion about it yeah and I think it's
the willingness to
trust
when you're in the zone because I think
a lot of times that actually scares us
and a lot of times we find reasons why
we shouldn't stay there where for me if
I'm if I get there I try to I fight to
stay there as long as possible even if
it doesn't make logical sense so I had
this two days ago two days ago I started
working on my YouTube thumbnails and
doing a deep dive on YouTube thumbnails
you know I've been playing around with
them and I'm always doing little
experiments but for whatever reason I
woke up I was thinking YouTube
thumbnails got inspired and just started
working and I started to really hit the
flow and as a result of that I pushed
everything else that I was doing like as
much as I could cancel and push away I I
canceled and pushed away because staying
in that zone allows for magic to be
created and so uh I made 81 thumbnails
that day for my channel and we'll see
we'll see the results you know I'm
pretty pleased with what we created and
uh it's just trusting that it's right
where a lot of times we find all these
reasons why we can't do it you're in the
Zone on something and then an email
comes in or a phone call comes in or you
look at your calendar and you're
supposed to do something else and I love
my calendar and I you with 95% of the
time I'm sticking to my calendar but
when you're in the zone it's the
willingness to push everything that you
said you were supposed to do because
something of more importance comes
through and that's where I've created so
many magical things for my business and
for my life like the Zone might be in
your life The Zone might be going for go
for a walk with Nina and it's just it's
just amazing so I'm gonna extend it by
another half hour or hour you know and
and the willingness to push the other
things because the the things that you
create when you're in the zone uh is
just magical and so I think a lot of
times we're afraid of it a lot of times
we second guess it a lot of times we
judge it and we end up stif it you know
you're quenching the spirit instead of
letting it in and just flowing in terms
of how I start the day usually it's now
with a with a song uh I have a believe
playlist that I have it's actually
public playlist on my channel anybody
can go check it out you may not like my
my taste in music but uh it's always I
just find music is the fastest way to
change your state so if you're tired and
you don't have energy or you're
procrastinating just put on put on music
that uh helps you feel how you want to
feel instead of how you currently are
feeling and that's I think the big
mistake a lot of people make is that
when you're feeling sad or low you don't
really want to put on a high energy song
you want to put on a low sad kind of
song and that just keeps you where you
are but there are some songs maybe maybe
you could tell us what it is for you on
but there are some songs that when it
comes on you just have to get up and
start mov it right like what's that song
for you if this song comes on you're
gonna have to get out of your seat and
just start moving maybe singing Maybe
dancing you just you can't help it
because it's such a great song you got
one I mean I have a lot of them but
anything upbeat that is is I'm gonna D
you did you see my video I don't know if
anybody seen my video when I was coming
out I'm coming out okay by Diana Ross
yeah that one right there gets me going
so that's the thing right like if you
play Diana Ross in the morning uh maybe
not the same song but you mixed it up or
some Legends you gonna you're GNA pick
uh you know Tina Turner or whoever it is
it's like if you start your day day with
that it's just GNA it's going to change
how you show up and like in 10 seconds
of that song coming on you're already a
different person
absolutely and so that's why I try to
start my day with and then and then I'll
go for a walk and I'll I'll uh I'll
listen to a top 10 video on my channel
because I want I want my in my ear I
want Oprah in my ear I want Steve Jobs
in my ear you know the the music gets me
feeling energetic like okay let's go
take on the day but the the the videos
of the famous entrepreneurs helps me
start to think bigger yeah and it's like
okay I I want to do something bigger
than what I'm currently doing and then
um at the end of the walk I'm looking
through my feedback from the community
so usually my Instagram DMS responding
to people and that is my I guess version
of gratitude it just connects me to the
work that what I'm doing is not just
talking to a camera you know in my
office yeah like it's actually reaching
people and whether it's five people or
500,000 people or five million people
it's feeling like what I do matters and
and again it's a fleeting uh feeling I
need it every day and so at the very
beginning of my journey the comments
were the thing that really saved me the
looking at my comments and knowing that
oh like somebody was impacted by my
message and I'm so grateful for that and
that kept me going to say okay what I'm
doing may not be changing the world yet
but it's changing that one person and so
I have to keep going uh so that I think
the morning routine what's the point of
a morning routine at least for me it's
to get a feeling so yeah a lot of times
people will just check the box like I
did this I did this I did this I did
this okay cool but do you feel ready to
take on the day because if not then
there's either something wrong in your
routine or you did it uh half-heartedly
and you got to do it with more intention
um remember I was doing an event in New
Mexico and uh a woman was in the front
row of my event and I asked her what's
the most important part of your morning
routine and she said I do the rosary so
she takes out her her you know prayer uh
the rosary and starts doing her prayers
I say well okay so what's the what's the
point of doing the Ros like well by the
end of it I feel uh connected to what
I'm doing and ready to go and start my
day awesome how many times you actually
feel connected like by the end of you
doing the rosary how much how many times
what percentage of the days do you
actually feel connected and ready to go
and start the day and she said like
40% so the other 60% she's she's doing
the words she's doing the action she's
saying it but she doesn't feel connected
because she's also stressed out about
something else because she's also making
breakfast because she's also watching
some video because she's she's doing
something else like well there's nothing
wrong with what you're doing you're just
not doing it with the intention that is
required great keep doing the rosary but
now focus in on doing it with the right
intention because the whole point of the
morning routine is to get the feeling so
I think a lot of a lot of people a lot
of um a lot of entrepreneurs a lot of
people who are go-getters and action
takers we love the feeling of just like
check check check or check the box they
did it but if you don't have the feeling
I've ready to take on the day with
boldness with courage with service with
belief then either go back and do it
again or add something to your morning
routine or or tweak it up a bit because
for me at least the point of the morning
routine is to get the feeling so you're
ready to take on the day Karen is a part
of our mve makers program and as part of
that we're doing um Instagram live too
see how I can help so what's on your
mind Karen how can I help what's going
on I'm here working with you because I
want to be better at uh videos on
YouTube because I've mastered Facebook
and Instagram and a bunch of other
things and I want to get out there and
do more YouTube videos for for my brand
I started off in advertising and I was a
senior VP creative director in
advertising so I learned a lot about
marketing and business and I rose up
pretty quickly I got cleos my first year
and then I quit to my parents horror to
write books and screenplays and movies
and everything and then I did well with
that and then I started to do books and
then I started to do what I call
self-help for people who wouldn't be
caught dead doing self-help like um I
had a book how to be happy Dam it which
is huge bestseller um and a bunch of
other books the bounceback book which
had a Red Rubber cover on it that um was
about resiliency psychology and I you
know I've sold over two million books
and courses uh in general I guess if you
would sum it up I'm a behavioral change
expert I've written a lot about I wrote
books on you know mastering habits and
and then I started doing it for online
courses but I also love marketing that
was like my first Passion in the
advertising world and so that's how I
wound up selling two million books and
courses was my creative mind my
marketing mind and so now I also help
entrepreneurs to build their brands and
stand out and help them to make six to
seven figure incomes so I have like a
little bit of both sides to me that's
sort of the the quander you know um I
joke there's um I joke I have the
Spider-Man curse Spider-Man they say his
gift was his curse his curse was his
gift so my gift is that I have so many
things I love to do my curse is I have
so many things that I love to do and I
know I have to like just kind of make up
my mind and stick with it and that's
what's kind of kept me paralyzed uh
creating my YouTube
channel all of those things like in that
combination That's What Makes You unique
that's what makes you care and that's
why people buy your books that's why
people work with you it's because it's
not just one thing but it's in the mix
of things the key is doing doing them
together not at the same time but
separate so it's like in the mix of of
uh Habit change and marketing and
telling a story doing that now it's like
how you're unique because in in any of
the other fields there's other people
who are great at those things but it's
like in the combination of them that
makes you special and stand out what
kind of content were you thinking of
doing for YouTube and then I can uh
dissect it and give you some feedback on
it
well I kind of been lately loving
helping entrepreneurs um and I have
courses on how to make courses I have a
course on make profitable courses
without the overwhelm and I have a
mastermind so I thought I wanted to do
more around helping entrepreneurs and
even executive coaches um and one of my
more successful courses was tweak a week
um now it Rhymes tweak a week but it
could also be like tweak a month or
tweak orderly or tweak your leadership
or tweak your brand like I you know
those small micro habit shifts those
small shifts that add up to big change
so I was thinking about doing a whole
slew of Maybe videos on that on tweaking
things you could tweak because that's
not as scary and as a behavioral change
expert I know that if you tell people
it's just a tweak you know that that
they're less afraid of change so there
are three different kinds of shows that
you can make and all of them have uh a a
role or fit with what you're doing and
but they serve different purposes so the
thought leadership show is the one that
everybody thinks of so you're G to talk
direct to camera and that could be tweak
a week that could be how to how to sell
two million books that could be you know
how to be more creative or how to
overcome the obstacles in your life or
personal development for people who
don't believe in personal value whatever
it is right like but it's it's Karen
direct a camera share in a message and
usually the easiest way to do that is
you book off a morning or an afternoon
per month and you sit down and you just
bang out videos you you already have the
knowledge like if I said Karen you know
what are five steps to selling a million
books you could come up with the five
steps pretty quickly yeah you could go
and just talk to them you don't need it
all scripted out and perfect and take
like two days to create this video you
could just go and start talking to it
and bring a lot of value because you're
you have the experience you don't have
to go do a whole bunch of research of
how to sell the million books you've
already done it so banging out thought
leadership videos is the best way to
build your long-term brand and then that
can be cut up for all sorts of different
platforms Instagram Facebook Twitter you
know you take a 30- second if you made a
15 minute video about how to sell a
million books you'll you'll have a lot
of moments in there that could be
clipped for the other platforms how
would I share it here on Instagram if I
clip the bigger one like how would I
share it here you either take a video
clip and you say okay here's a here's a
45 second moment of fire from my long
form video and then you turn that into
an Instagram real or and you take a
quote if you say something really
powerful that's a oneliner you turn that
into a picture and you post that as a
quote and put it up on Instagram and and
put a caption with and then do I send
them back to YouTube because I want that
traffic on YouTube you don't need do I
to now like usually uh traffic that
comes from Instagram to YouTube really
underperforms on YouTube oh because
they're not sticking around for the
video but when somebody's in Instagram
mode they're usually scrolling and
they're spending you know a few seconds
at a time they don't want to sit there
and go watch a 15 minute video typically
Instagram brain is like short detention
span like went quick hits of dopamine
and YouTube is more for like longer form
content and some people that are there
are are more open to longer form content
exactly so we don't we don't want to
move people from Instagram to YouTube
because we'll get we'll get people who
don't typically watch long firm content
email is great if you have an email list
if you use Instagram to like build up
your email list and then we're emailing
people the video they can watch it at
their own pace on their own time and
they're way more likely to then consume
it as opposed to coming from an
Instagram link okay but that kind of
thought leadership content is is
relatively easy to make for someone like
you who has the experience already and
so whatever your writing process is you
can you can use the starting point of
that for your YouTube videos in that
coming up with what are the titles going
to be what are the topics going to be so
if you said okay I'm gonna sit down next
week and I'm record four videos and here
are the topics of the first four videos
and just the bullet points of what
you're going to say so the title is
going to be five ways to sell a million
bucks and just bullet point out what the
five things are you could then go make a
15minute video talking about those five
you don't need to have the whole thing
scripted but at least knowing that when
you get to filming you're not just gonna
stand in front of the camera and have to
Wing the whole thing and then have no
idea what to say right it's like I'm
gonna make these four videos and I have
my bullet points for each one and then
it becomes a lot easier because you have
you have the framework to be able to
make a video within so first show is
thought leadership show so we covered
that uh Second show we're going to do
bis Dev show we're thinking about who
are people who can refer ideal clients
to you so it cost money to work with you
and we want to now attract in people who
will pay even more to work with you so
oneon-one clients for you are not going
to be people who are just starting up
and have no idea what they're doing and
don't have a message to share yet and
just kind of fre that's what the videos
are for you know the videos can be
for total beginners but the bizde show
if they're going to work with some with
you was like okay who has access to the
people who are ideal clients for you and
I think when we met in New York we
talked about U agents like speaking
agents book agents Talent agents because
they're representing people who might be
getting paid $100,000 a speech or might
be getting a six figure advance for
their book and they know the value of
working with a professional already
because they have an
agent but the agent can't do what you're
doing the agent is not going to go and
design a course for that person but the
agent is responsible for bringing their
talent opportunities and
ideas so if you knew all of the book
agents speaking agents Talent agents in
New York City you're gonna get access to
a ton of New Deal flow for your company
that's great I love that you're good
you're
good listen and you're in New York City
you have no excuse right I mean if you
were in some tiny little town and it's
hard to get to know people and no no big
players come through the city okay I
might hear you out but Karen you live in
New York City look at look at those
Towers behind you there's a ton of
there's a ton of talent a ton of money a
ton of opportunity there and so the show
becomes not you trying to get the talent
on the show although you could but it's
how do you get the agents how do you get
the people who know the talent to come
on the show which is usually much easier
to get who has a show talking to book
agents no that that's clever I love it
nobody
right nobody may have ever asked them
for an interview and you're coming in
not asking not asking for any kind of
sale you're asking just for an interview
to tell their story and see what they're
seeing in the market but in the process
of doing that they get to know you like
you trust you build awareness it's like
oh you what do you do Karen oh you do
courses I wonder if that might be a fit
for my client if I wanted to also do uh
some Executive coaching who would be the
one step two step dance to do Executive
coaching with the behavioral change uh
aspect which is another signature
strength that I love doing another
passion of mine so executive like you're
looking at CEOs you're looking at
entrepreneurs yeah exactly which one or
both both both yeah so it's like where
do they hang out so for example if
you're trying to Target uh executive
you're trying to Target entrepreneurs
highing entrepreneurs you know most
entrepreneurs can't afford you to come
in and be their executive coach right
right so what do they need to be taking
home to justify coming and working with
you but it's a it's a higher end
entrepreneur so where are these highend
entrepreneurs uh going and who are they
hanging out with and who has their ear
so you know in the book world it's the
agents in the entrepreneur World I'd be
looking at high-end lawyers
highing accountants IP attorneys like if
somebody's hiring an IP attorney or the
high in lawyers like at the big firms
not not the startup kind of how to get
your business Incorporated for $200
lawyer but the the ones who are like a$
thousand dollar an hour
lawyers those lawyers are helping the
entrepreneurs with their negotiations
and their deal structure and all the but
the entrepreneur might be a total basket
case and need
help this is good you're good so like
okay well here's Ken right I love it
yeah so if you knew all of the all of
the lawyers in New York City who were
charging a thousand dollar an hour
helping entrepreneurs and again at that
point entrepreneur sometimes when I say
entrepreneur I think like startup these
are like real business owners they're
already hiring professionals and they've
hired a professional lawyer but but the
you're not a competition with the lawyer
you're not touching legal stuff and they
they don't want to handle personal
development stuff they wish their client
was not a basket case right true they'd
be a lot easier to work with true so
yeah that's where it's like let's get a
hey you're you sounds like you're
struggling with a lot of stuff right now
maybe you should talk to Karen because I
think she can help you so that's a bis
Dev show the third show is to
demonstrate the process so thought
leadership bis Dev demonstrate the
process and with that it would be
bringing on students who' gone through
your course
and just coaching them what what are we
doing right now I mean this isn't this
isn't necessarily going to be a YouTube
video but you're in my movement makers
program so let's go live together uh I
don't know what you're gonna ask me
there's no it wasn't like four pages of
notes before we start it's like here's
Karen all right how can I help Karen and
then and then we go and the whole point
is you know when you're saying oh my God
you're so good or that's a great idea
like you can do the same thing for your
course members right when people are
going through and they spend half an
hour with you they're going to be saying
oh my God Karen that's so smart oh holy
cow I didn't think about that without
you even try because you know this stuff
inside out and so if you had a show
where you are bringing on people who
have gone through the course you can say
that they're in your course now it helps
promote the course right somebody here
just discovered about Movie Makers I
didn't know about it before because
we're doing this thing but the point
isn't just to sell the course or here to
sell Movie Makers it's just gives a
little exposure but then you're bringing
value helping uh and it's usually the
most fun to make because there's
somebody in front of you not just a
camera and you're actually helping
somebody through whatever challenges
they're facing right now I cannot
believe I am on a live with Evan Carmel
himself this is it I love well first off
I love the energy what a what a great
start to kick us off uh sh is part of
our mve for makers program and as part
of that we're doing an Instagram live
together as well so the theme you picked
was navigating your next chapter with
Clarity so what's on your mind how can I
help I am embarking on that next chapter
for me which is having started my
coaching practice this year which
actually focuses on women like myself
who are actually also navigating their
next chapter and so I figured that you
know the easiest way to start would be
to work with folks who are dealing with
some of the same kinds of issues or
going through a similar trajectory or
Journey similar to myself and so I guess
I wanted to top it up with you a little
bit um
regarding you know starting something
new and regarding you know like you are
so amazing at branding yourself and so
amazing at what you do and so I just
wanted to just pick your brains a little
bit and terms of especially
starting and looking at what I am
looking to focus in on in terms of any
tips or any ideas in terms of how I can
brand myself and brand the things that I
do to gain an amazing following I don't
know if it's gonna be quite like you but
you know at least a good start no it's
gonna be it's gonna be it's gonna be
your style it's going to be great so
listen for me branding is an emotion and
it's what do you want people to feel
every time they interact with you in
person in a in a coaching session in an
Instagram live in a YouTube video when
they're reading your post when they
visit your website how do you want to
make people feel and so I even looking
behind you on your wall it says soar you
got a eagle soaring which is great when
you first joined here you had all this
energy and excitement it's like oh my
God we're doing this live right so it
start with that like what do you want
people to feel have you been through the
one word
exercise no I haven't okay so I wrote
about it in buil to serve as well as
your one word but if you had to think
about your most important core value as
a human what would you pick I have a lot
of words but just like something that
comes off like off the top dream cool so
let's we'll run with that for now it
doesn't have to be the final one but
ultimately you think about your most
important core value let's say it was
dream then the greatest gift that you
can bring other people is to allow them
to dream as well the greatest gift I can
give people is belief and it's Al also
the thing that we need the most help
with ourselves to The Next Step so my
next step is on the other side of even
more belief yes your next step is on the
on the other side of an even bigger
dream and so the greatest contribution
that we can give people is our values
and that's your brand
so it may be worth spending a little bit
of of time thinking about or go through
the exercises in the book just figure
out is it dream is it something else but
running with dream for
now then you get to put that through
your content filter so what kind of
posts are you putting do they make me
want to dream a bigger dream what's on
the background in your wall does it make
me want to dream a bigger dream what's
your morning routine does it make you
want to dream a bigger dream how do
people leave you in your coaching
sessions When I visit your website if
you if you run the filter of dream
through everything that you make and
create it starts to change one how you
show up but then two how people talk
about you which then becomes your brand
wow I definitely will take the time to
go through that exercise and really
figure out what that is for me um and a
in a in a big way wow I really like that
and so you're saying what I'm
understanding is that you know the value
that I live myself is what comes out to
others and others perceive it and and
embody that so it's not just saying Hey
I want to put this out for people but
it's I have to live it myself and um you
know it it should emanate from me I
guess is what what I'm hearing
yeah it should be how you show up not
just in your business like your your
brand is not just a business thing it's
you yeah and so if it's dream if it's
sore if it's something else then it's
still what you need the most and just by
you living becomes an example for others
to
follow and the the challenge for most
people is they don't have Clarity on on
what they stand for they've never been
asked that question or answered that
question and then when they're showing
up they have a a mixture of tons of
messages right so you've got sore behind
you on the wall there was so much energy
and excitement when you joined like all
of these great things but it makes it
difficult for me to talk about you what
are people gonna say and so you're
they're forced to come up with their own
story their own version as opposed to
saying oh like Bel or dream she's gonna
help you dream she's gonna help you
unlock your next big dream like if you
can give people the language then it's
easier to spread the brand as well
so if you run that filter so you first
you figure out what your one word is
when once you get that you run that
filter through everything that you do
like you might need to change your
background you might say huh like that
brown or gray or whatever the background
is maybe that's not dream maybe that's
blah maybe those are Cloudy Skies you
know we need to have some energy and po
for for a dream right maybe you change
some of the artwork or maybe it
completely reflects you know who you are
and the miss when you walk into your
office does it make you feel like you
want a dream bigger and if not change it
up maybe the maybe the Gray's got to go
and now it's it's rainbows or pink or
white or blue skies or whatever makes
you light up you know the brand that I
wear here like people asking what's with
the paper airplane well the paper
airplane is a symbol of belief for me
where I want to to help entrepreneurs
and I think entrepreneurs a a plain
simple is us we start somewhere and we
want to go somewhere else like we wanna
we don't just want to stay where we are
forever and we're soaring to new heights
that we've never soar to before but if
you watch my videos and you see the
plane go across the screen you'll hear
it break the sound barrier you'll hear
it like hit the sonic boom there's like
a jet plane and then it goes boom and
for me why I did that was I wanted a a
paper airplane to break the sound
barrier it's not POS possible Right like
it doesn't happen but that's belief and
that's what we do as entrepreneurs and
so it it all runs through what I think
of as belief from the the Doritos behind
me on my wall to the neck braids to the
outfit to the content I'm making but
it's not just an act yeah like on the
weekend I'm wearing my
hoodie
I no I love that and and you know it's
it's like once I see those colors you
know from you I always like oh that's
Evan you know when I see the paper
airplane so definitely not only like if
you asked me what your one word um was I
would note instantly it was belief
because it comes through in everything
you say um as well and so that is
definitely something um worth of note so
the folks that I um I serve um is
primarily
women and it's helping them to um
discover their distinct purpose at this
next chapter in their lives and the
reason I do that is because you know
it's something that I had to go through
in my journey and in fact to be quite
candid and I it's not just women but a
lot of people we all have different
chapters because we're constantly
evolving as people um you know who who I
was 10 years ago 20 years ago is not who
I am today you know with with with that
you know um whether it's dream or it's
sore or whatever that one word is once I
go through that full exercise um I think
it's definitely something I'm going to
take to heart to make sure that you know
when we talk about discovering your
purpose and what that means and what
when it comes to embarking on that next
chapter how does it make you feel you
know how how how do you present yourself
how do you show up and so yeah so I
definitely uh feel exactly what you're
saying so to take it a level deeper from
my perspective your your one word your
most important core value doesn't change
with time so and that might be helpful
in in selecting what the word is because
it's not just a branding thing about how
to how people see you it's it's how you
actually are and so if you look at dream
as an example does sharifa in 10 years
now not care about
dream no absolutely not in fact when
people would ask me um in fact when I
graduated from college younger years ago
um you know what is like your favorite
quote or favorite statement I would
always say if you can dream it you can
achieve it oh so that is something yeah
so that's why dream just came yeah was
let me I'm G to show you one of my
favorite quotes which I found I had on
my wall before I even uh came up with my
one word you get to see behind the
scenes I love that okay so this this
this poster I had up on my wall like way
before I even that's the the your one
word book built to serve but before I
even wrote These I had this on the wall
and uh hold on wait going the wrong way
can you see the first word
believe right so I the quote just
similar to you about the dreaming it
just spoke to me without it without me
knowing that like that's what I was
going to then build my entire life
around um but I think in looking at what
you
do
uh it's it's a fantastic filter because
what happens when you accomplish your
dream well you have to dream
again right bigger go for the next
stream we did that great now we got to
go for the next Stream So I think when
you're helping the women that you're
coaching first off is giving them
permission again to dream again
absolutely when was the last time that
they actually dreamed where if you think
about when when we were kids we we would
we would ride a broomstick and pretend
it was a horse and like we would we
would dream of I want to be a baseball
player and a firefighter at the same
time he's like all of these nobody tells
us that it's not possible and then at
some point reality hits Us in the face
and like oh you can't do any of that
stuff and and all of our dreams get
squashed out where I think step one for
you when you're coaching people just
allowing them again permission to dream
to say the crazy things on their mind to
say the crazy things in their hearts
that you're afraid to tell your husband
or your parents or your kids or the
community around you because it sounds
so stupid like writing a book who are
you to write a book starting the
business who are you to write instantly
it's our own voices that shut us down
not even the people around us like we
shut our own dreams down almost by
reflex now right and so I could see that
being incredibly valuable for you just
giving somebody permission and a space
to dream again and I'm sure that will
lead to tons of emotions and tears and
like this is the first time I've even
thought about this for decades right uh
and then the ongoing work is okay now
let's go let's go start to accomplish
it's not just about dreaming we got take
the steps to hit our dreams and then
once we do we need to dream again like
dreaming is you're never done there's
always a new bigger dream that we have
to go off and and accomplish and so uh
that's powerful work like if you can
apply that methodology it's powerful
work for the for the clients that you're
going to bring on if you wanted people
to dream with you and that's going to be
your first calls like let's dream
together okay what their environment
have to look like do you tell them like
if they're in their car do they have to
pull over if they're in a really busy
space do they have to quiet themselves
do you lead them through a guided
meditation do you breathe together
before you even start a session if you
see them like they're freaking out how
do you calm them down and get into a
space of even being able to dream how do
you make them feel safe and heard and
seen and not judged by whatever else you
know they they're they're about to tell
you the things that they are embarrassed
to tell anybody else so even in the pre
setup to the dream there's so many
things that you could do and there's no
right answer the right answer is what
you love doing right so if you if you
make everybody lie down for three
minutes and just guide them through a
breathing exercise before they then
actually start their session or you make
them sit on the floor get a pillow and
let's sit on the floor or get out of
your office environment and let's go sit
in a comfortable chair to allow us to
dream I'm just pulling that stuff here
right but whatever actually makes the
most sense for you having that as part
of the ritual like I see I see lily pads
behind you and I see an eagle and I see
another bird on the other side and I see
like a a purple tree which is great
Dreaming by the way anyway and so my
favorite color great so but like a
purple tree is a great representation of
dreaming like who a purple trees don't
exist but we're going to make them exist
and so that becomes part of the brand
right why is there only one little bit
of purple when the whole wall is like
gray and brown right let's let's pop it
purple this is the dreaming room that
we've just stepped into right but if if
nature is really important to you maybe
like asking them to do weird things to
break their pattern really helps because
they're stuck in a pattern and a story
right so uh example you could
say go go somewhere in your house where
there's a
plant and I want you to touch on I want
you to hold the
plant just hold the leaf go outside and
put your hand on some grass touch a
tree like something because nature is
obviously something that you connect to
you're breaking me out of my usual
routine of okay here's another Zoom call
let's see what she's gonna say and I'm
like I'm touching a plant and I'm I'm
but that break gives them the safety in
the space to then start to dream and so
again I'm just making stuff up but
injecting those things into your process
yes and it's like man I I came out a
different person I didn't even know
those things were still in me this is
amazing absolutely so it's not just a
brand it's life because if you think
about you know if you have kids or
husband or the friends around you your
cousins your nieces and nephews do you
want them to build to dream bigger as
well and it and it's it's through how
you show up every day not just the
speeches that you give or the posts that
you pick so if you use dream as the
filter for everything then then if
you're going to now like that's at the
highest level we went deep on how do you
set up your clients to deal with the
dream and there's so many things you can
do if you then apply that to your
content look at your Instagram page does
it make you sharifa want to dream more
when you look at your own
stuff and if it's no then great let's
start to change it yeah
like what do you need to see would you
subscribe to you would you follow
you and not at a egotistical way but
think about think about the sharifa from
10 years ago who was struggling and
didn't know what to do next is this the
content that she badly needs what you're
posting right now yeah and if it's it's
not cool great let's change it
yeah and put the lens of of of um of
dream over it and it's a constant
evolution and it's never perfect and
we're always great and start going right
so you can look at your last five posts
and say okay I'm going to make five new
posts around dream because you tapped
into the source there and you you did it
with your podcast post and not only does
it get more engagement and and
connection and impact but it also feels
good you know it's like more meaningful
for you it's true first of all I want to
figure out if I'm making this up or
somebody else has already labeled you
this oh or if it's just my own but have
you ever yeah have you ever been called
I I refer to you as the introverted Tony
Robbins whenever I'm trying to like put
you out there and talk about the program
I'm in and who you are it's like Tony
Robbins without all the hand
clapping I mean you are are so
inspirational and your message is is
like so on and um I have to admit I
didn't read momentum started it but ever
since I've been on the calendar just to
have this this live um I'm embodying it
it it's been it's like I need to up my
game and be on my aame and and really
like make this worthwhile so um well
let's go let's let's get Kayla and first
off thank you I mean that's very
humbling uh you know Tony was one of my
and still is uh mentors and I I looked
at him from afar in the early days you
know I got his CD program back when
people bought CDs uh you know read the
books and he was the first big person
that I did a collaboration with on my
channel and he's been on now three or
four times on the channel and you know
actually got to hang out with him
backstage and all that kind of stuff but
at the beginning it was just somebody
who I admired from afar and uh yeah very
humbling words thank you for that I'll
uh I'll I'll um own it you see it yeah
I'll own it thank you the inted John R
okay yeah I could figure out if that was
my own label for you if I I heard that
somewhere nobody has called me that so
thank you and and yes how can I help I
started a business two years ago working
with spiritually gifted kids called it
young ascended masters my third question
if we get to it I'm I'm now branded
under my name and under that with my
website but we'll put that on hold for a
second my most immediate question I'm
going like from lukewarm to totally
Allin on is my work in
2018 started with direct work with kids
running groups and and being a mentor
and a teacher to them shifting into of
course working there with their parents
and now it has reshaped itself again to
where I'm coaching conscious parenting
coaching and the diffence with that is
it's more of a spiritually aware person
that's willing to go inside and reflect
on how they're impacting their kids bit
of background I have a a master's degree
in education and actually worked with
special needs kids that were emotionally
challenged and behaviorally challenged
so I know all the social emotional stuff
so all those gifts are coming into play
today um the is issue is I truly feel
like I'm just starting out I am like
social media illiterate since being on
your Chanel I have upgraded my YouTube
channel um so all of your training I've
been binge watching not Netflix but your
trainings let's go um so you're in my
head so all my questions that I want to
ask I kind of know the answers which is
great um so specifically to where I'm at
my goal is to get up my sales page I I'm
just going to be converting to a
business address for my emails I've got
about 220 people on an email list maybe
52 subscribers on my YouTube channel
like none on my Ig um and I wanted like
where do I find an audience of conscious
parents I need to really put myself in
front of this audience I don't have a
big problem with the camera and all this
I have plans to even my lead magnet is
going to be a series of four or five
short recordings so I maybe I'll stop
talking there no that's that's a great
start you know the easiest way to start
is to do a coaching show so if you have
200 people on your email list even if
you send them emails one by one to say
hey I'm starting a new show where I'm
coaching parenting conscious parents uh
it's for free but the caveat is is going
to be turned into a YouTube video would
you like to come on and normally my
coaching is whatever an hour and then
now you get this for free and and some
people will not want to do it uh and you
know share personal things and not want
to get into it and others will you know
it's like yes go ahead that's where I'm
I'm definitely hearing everything you're
suggesting and that makes perfect sense
to me and it sounds actually kind of
exciting um yeah believe it or not that
sounds exciting when it comes to getting
someone to talk about parenting issues
or or issues with their kids is where
another question like like how would you
suggest I I caveat that I don't want
someone to not speak honestly with what
their issues are because that's what I'm
coaching but should I kind of set it up
as yes I'm going to record this you have
my guarantee and maybe the final
approval whether I put it up or not if I
promise to edit out anything that is of
a sensitive nature you think that might
be a way to get more
people
willing I I wouldn't lead with that if
it comes up then you can consider it and
obviously you're not trying to make
somebody look bad right just just by not
that I you know know you super well but
just the energy that you're putting up
it's not like I can't wait to get these
people on my show and show them what a
terrible parent they are and screw them
right I mean you're you're you're loving
you're kind you're trying to serve and
toble to do that you have to actually
know somebody's story and that's the
point of coming on on your show and
again some people are super
uncomfortable and won't say Yes and
others they just value the the time to
spend with you just just like we put
this on my calendar and your calendar
and now you're starting to get some
momentum like oh my God I talk to EV and
I gotta get a couple things happening
you I gotta get things in place
similarly the your conversation with
them could be a giant source of
excitement for them and the cist to help
them go and make changes in their life
so we our brain always goes to the scary
scariest worst case scenario uh but
there are some people who would who
would say yes and be honored and be glad
and love to come on your show and talk
to you especially when you're not trying
to make them look bad you know if people
are going to go on Dr Phil and do what
they do where he's trying to make them
look bad uh you know they'll they'll
come on your show and talk to you um a
model to look at I was just talking to
RIT safy I don't know if you know RIT or
not but um he's got a YouTube channel
and a Netflix uh show around teaching
people about finances um his channel is
called I will teach you to be rich if
you look that up and the show is him
doing basically a zoom call with a
husband and wife who are fighting over
money and they don't know what to do and
usually it's one person wants to spend
more the other person wants to save more
and you know it's causing a ton of
conflict in their life and he comes on
and he basically just coaches them and
he turns it into YouTube content and a
Netflix show so them coming on it
doesn't just go to YouTube it goes to
Netflix as well for other people to see
about their financial problems um and
you know people don't want to talk about
their financial problems and that
they're $400,000 in debt and it's
causing relationship issues and and
similarly you know RIT is not trying to
get them to look bad he's not trying to
screw them over he's he's trying to help
like genuinely help and so it might be
um a model just to look at to to know
that people you know will say yes that
if you're trying to serve and help um
and educate that people will come on the
fact that you are excited about it is a
good sign yeah I I've worked with enough
groups in the parents and and there is
an authentic you know I keep coming up
trying to come up with my one word you
know believe like you've got it you
there's just nothing better than that
but you know between authentic and real
and all that um it may not come across
as professional as like this little
mind thing in don't go filming in your
car don't go filming outside walking but
that's what you do you know so I've got
kind of a mindset stuff to overcome too
when it comes to some of the business
yeah it's like this background seriously
once a week I spent so much energy
trying to go around my house how can I
change this but I'm in a bedroom and
this is my backdrop and you know so that
that honestly has kept me from recording
my background like isn't that ridiculous
I I mean I see how ridiculous it is but
it it's and that's where you you know
it's like just show up just turn your
camera on when you've got that energy
and passion and I've lost so many
opportunities seriously because those
are my background yeah it's crazy I mean
one thank you for sharing a lot of
people are too afraid to to share what
the truth is and it's easy to come with
all these reasons that are legit reasons
but the real answer is just like it's
just fear and that's okay and like even
just speaking it out loud about your
background now means the background has
less control over you you recognize how
ridiculous it is like okay now it's it's
I've voiced it it's it's kind of out of
my system H and it and it allows for
momentum to happen um an easy way around
it is uh videos have to get made and
this is what I tell myself it's like
videos have to get made uh would I love
everything to be in my office and
perfect sound and perfect lighting and
perfect everything of course but videos
still have to get made and so last month
I was on a cruise and I went to Alaska
and iil videos yeah so for my videos for
my main Channel with three point
whatever million subscribers I go out on
my balcony and I just take my phone out
I guess you can't see me gesturing but
just take my phone out and I I press
record and film videos from the balcony
uh because videos have to get out and so
that uh putting that in my calendar like
this you could have said no to this you
know if this wasn't in your calendar to
meet me you could have said I'm not
gonna film today I'm not gonna go live
I'm not gonna I got my background is all
wrong right but it's in the calendar and
now you're you know I'm gonna be going
live by myself and like where is she
right so you have to show up and so
that's where you know the commitment
makes a difference and especially if
you're now going to commit to coaching
other people and they're going to show
up you now have to show up even if on
the day of you don't like your
background again you still have to show
up because they're in your calendar yeah
and so you when I've done a number of
podcasts and stuff and it's when it's
like next to each other and there's all
these bright backgrounds and all you
know so anyway enough with that do you
have the ability right now to jump on my
YouTube page yeah what's the name I can
go look it up just off your name yeah so
I've been working on my banner I
I I it's not extending all the way
across the page it's good enough at this
point with what I was working with but
um so first impressions would be great
um what's behind the thumbnails what's
behind door number two isn't something
I'm extremely proud of but I at least
was able to get something out for you to
have a reaction to this is a great start
so at the beginning you know your your
profile picture is easy to see it's
zoomed in it's nice your your banner and
there's canva templates that you can use
for all of this stuff but the banner
you've got your name it says conscious
parenting coach youth Mentor spiritual
guide healing sound Oracle and then
there's a link to the website um that's
where if you have anything any
reputation any awards any anything that
helps you stand out uh in terms of a
accreditation or I don't know if you've
been featured in an article or just
anything to show that you're not just
some startup you know like I just
started this last week kind of thing uh
because people who are coming here have
no idea who you are and so it's good to
have well I I can put I can put like
those fun letters behind my name for
education I mean at least it would be a
masters of education knowing that I'm
going to be working with social
emotional issues with your kids and you
know that might give me some credibility
in the real world um yeah I mean for
some people
that that means nothing and for others
it means a lot like you have a master
degree in education you're a licensed
intervention specialist you've worked
with teachers and kids for 15 years you
know I'm just reading I'm on your
website now I didn't I didn't memorize
this before coming on oh okay uh like
those kinds of things could be good in
the banner just so that I know that oh
you're legit like you've been doing this
for a while you're not just uh you know
an accountant who then decided overnight
to become a you know a therapist or a
coach or a guide um right so that's
great if you were just on my website it
it's under young ascended masters it's a
beautiful website whoever did it I mean
again I would make changes now that I
know a little bit more but it it's it's
fine yet Kayla Casey my company name is
under Kayla Casey doing business as
young anded masters just in allowing for
the expansion in the future and all that
um obviously my YouTube channel is under
my name um I know branding your name is
is like the most important thing when
you're getting started so like when I'm
even talking to people and being with
people I do have a a website under my
name that will redirect to my website
like what are what are your thoughts on
this like schizophrenic branding that I
got myself into this is not that bad and
I've seen way way way worse than this so
uh I would stress out too much about it
uh I I always lean in on a personal
brand more than a website or a name um
especially with something like this like
if I'm going to be trusting my you're
talking about one of the most intimate
things that people care about right
their Cas right right
so of anything is like well who am I
gonna get who am I gonna talk to and
that you care and that you know you have
experience and that you're going to help
me and that's where a logo doesn't do
nearly as much as a
face right right so I would put
everything under your name and it's
great that your YouTube channel already
is uh I'm assuming Kayla Casey was
already taken and that's why you have
837 8673 at the end of it um it was just
assigned oh I didn't have anything to do
with that you know I'll have yeah that's
worth looking at because I I'd assume
Kayla case is like it's a pretty rare
name right yeah so two a yeah my
thumbnail is that really Cayo with two
A's yeah um so you know if you were John
Smith it'd be a lot harder uh there's a
few Evan Carmichaels there's a Evan
carmichel who's a priest in he's a
pastor in Hawaii uh so I think he's like
evanor carel Evan do Caro so whenever
there's a new platform I kind of have to
get it out get my name before he does
but uh you should be you should be able
to change that and that's where I would
lean in on uh your personal brand
because young ascended masters it speaks
to what you do but it's it's harder to
remember uh and question is what's a
what's an ascended master and unless I'm
in my Niche group you know people don't
have a clue yeah there's not as much of
an emotion connection as it would be to
and I'm sure you know you've got the
logo and it's like a it looks like the
Earth kind kind of shining from the from
the uh from the space or something um
which is cool but your face will do a
lot more like oh that's the woman okay
that's who I get I think that she cares
and that's what we want to I mean you
have a meet Kayla section on your
website which is awesome uh you know
that's
that's yeah and I've got know my story
on the about page yeah it's a giant
story which is I mean it's not some
people will read that like if I'm really
try do I work with this woman or not and
seeing your story and what you went
through and you know from you know age
four your sister died and like all of
this stuff uh that connection is
something people have to you where you
know young ascended masters doesn't
really mean much to me right right yeah
there there's a lot of words on that
website you know it was like my first
and it was a learning experience but you
know it's still good it's you know where
it's going to be for a little while and
like some people people are emotional
buyers and they just buy right away and
they'll say okay who okay I like her
okay she's got experience okay she's
been doing this for 15 years great okay
let me call her and and that people just
do that but others are much more they
need more convincing they're more
logical they want more details they want
more information and so that's where
telling your story really helps like
okay like she's really thought this
through and she's had a lot of
experience and I connect with some of
the things she's talking about so it's
good to have a mix of both and so I
don't think your website is uh like the
website's not the problem so keep the
website so what would so if you're gonna
identify a problem what what are we
saying you've made one video in seven
months so that's a problem oh well no
okay all right now so we'll go back well
that's a problem you're I asked and you
told me that's good um yeah so now now
like you have you have content like you
have your website that's great and you
and you have your programs and it says
how people can hire you and it your
offerings and your services and whether
it's uh private sessions or
homeschooling or mentorship or
Consulting like you've got that so
people can find out about you like
basically if they find out about you
they know how to work with you so the
challenge becomes how do you get people
to find out about you right right and
it's all content I mean I I almost
started a 40-day blitz the other like a
month ago like again preparing for this
and the videos that are out there right
now the five or six um last year when
the website
was being presented uh May 31st I was I
challenged myself to do and that's what
it's called it
it's the title sucks but again I wanted
to just at least upload it and put it
out there 31 days of yam yam young
ascended masters oh my God what an
acronym um in May so every day I posted
on Facebook just because I really wasn't
even into YouTube and all that but I did
a 5 to 10 minute video every day so I've
got all those recordings to upload now
again they really aren't the best but
they tell each one tells stories about
the kids that I'm working with so it
gives some background and it's fun and
playful um yeah so so great I mean I
would I would start releasing some of
them so you have you have one video that
went up three days ago featuring a teen
named Grant uh that's two hours which is
awesome uh I see your background you
know it's changed a little bit it's good
I see the full background here now which
is I like
it uh so now it's getting more content
up the other thing that we want to make
sure we do is you have set this video
for kids and this this is one of the
it's just it's confusing how YouTube
words it but for every video that you
put up you want to say that it's not
made for kids I thought I had it marked
not for kids so this one um well
there's something in there there's
another switch that says can people
under 18 watch this but then right above
it was is this intended for kids and I
said no but I said yes can people under
18 watch it so maybe that's yeah double
check the settings with Grant because
it's it's listed on their YouTube kids
uh and what it also means is that people
for videos under kids people cannot
leave comments oh okay so comments are
automatically turned off uh so that's
something that we would want to
definitely fix uh your other videos yeah
your other video is is fine uh in terms
of that setting yeah I think they are
and you have a couple days is day four
day three day I know you've said not to
do series like that in days but given
this was like and again people can watch
it out of order so what do you suggest
um I did go and re-watch your videos on
the thumbnail naming and somewhat
provocative titles I looked at years
they were pretty long so yeah um one
question I have those are some really
good titles I I think um that would make
really good longer version recordings on
those topics um what would you suggest
because I really as I made those titles
I I'm making mental notes on on what I
can do um once I do that these 31 days
in May aren't that important to get
noticed so just like use those titles
put new
videos should I end up taking those that
series out no okay so I I wouldn't take
anything out I wouldn't worry about
taking anything out and the titles are
pretty good you know like the most
important thing in inner compass for
teens you're never too old to find your
purpose in life
uh so you know unlock your child's
potential they Master within so you're
getting some some titles what I would
focus on to where you're at right now is
one making longer videos so the one with
Grant is two hours which is great the
other ones are seven minutes seven
minutes three minutes three minutes like
a three minute video is basically dead
it's not gonna go anywhere so and they
were intended to do that now I do have
like two hour presentations out there
they're not my content unfortunately
it's material and my written and
everything else but it's under an
organization that I used to work for or
work with can you um can you use it or
no well it it's it should be on my
playlist there should be listed once you
open the channel under um I see four
sections so got a bunch of interview
I've got an interview playlist and I've
got what's called uh presentation
conscious children can can you use it
can you use the uh presentations or no
that's somebody else's rights no use it
in what I mean it's on it's on my
channel as me I mean I I show up when
people search on it which is why I I
mean it's just a copy paste under a
playlist people don't consume playlists
so no like can you actually put it up as
a video on your channel I've asked for
the material and it just isn't something
that I'm gonna get okay no problem now I
can certainly take lot it's you know
tons of great material that I will just
re-record as my own um so yeah even if
you take those same slides and just do
it yourself again like that could be
cool um yeah but what I where for where
you're at right now the most important
thing is getting consistent content up
and not worrying about everything being
perfect so that's a combination of your
the ones you've already done what you've
already filmed that might be on Facebook
or somewhere else
and turn it into YouTube content and
coaching videos of reach out to your
list of 200 people and say hey I'm
starting the new show if you want to be
coach for free and it goes on my YouTube
channel and of course you're not going
to make anybody look bad I wouldn't lead
with if you don't like it I'll take it
down but okay if somebody really asks
like of all the interviews I've done and
coaching sessions that I've done over
the years maybe one or two like they
really said hey like can we not post
that and fine okay can we cut this P bit
out like I didn't mean to throw my dad
under the bus like that cool we can cut
that you know but it's them asking not
because as soon as you say can I you
know they get final approval then like
oh I don't like how I look here and I
don't like how I said that and it
becomes this non-stop game um they
tricken out and yeah they sleep on it
yeah so so don't offer it but if
somebody really doesn't like it then
sure you're not I mean that's not you're
not in the business of trying to make
somebody look bad or feel uncomfortable
um but that I think that for where you
are right now like you everything could
be a little better sure but you've
already got like could your website be
better sure could the banner be better
sure could the thumbnails be better sure
but like so could mine you know like
it's always it could always be better
it's never done being better but the
thing that we're missing is we just
don't have enough content and so that's
the next starting point is you making
your videos whether they're releasing
the day's videos whether it's you
redoing like the presentation videos or
or and or coaching parents with whatever
is on their mind with their kids right
now and getting that consistently up and
then from there we can start to tweak
everything of okay let's let's let's fix
the thumbnails let's tweak our Banner
there's a lot like once you have content
to work with you can do a lot more with
it versus just planning planning
planning planning getting like
structured but no actual content to play
with right Instagram um what if I know
the answerers do both so I won't even
ask the
question yeah I mean the easiest thing
to do with Instagram is take clips of
your YouTube long form so you don't even
need to make unique Instagram content
you can if you want to but if you're
making long form YouTube videos then you
can clip some of the the content 30
second Clips 45 second Clips to take
that to Instagram uh great onliners I'm
sure when you're talking to parents you
come up with these like onliners that
maybe you've never said before
you know that could be turned into an
Instagram graphic or a tweet um so the
key is getting if you have long form
YouTube content that allows you to be on
every platform without creating new
content right learn the howt I've got a
whole binder of howtos between canva and
editing and the YouTube and yeah it's
quite a quite an adventure so but it's
it's all awesome yeah coach coach Kathy
uh in the chat also in Movie Maker says
analysis paralysis just do it and then
tweak it which is oh totally in my head
yeah exactly yeah which all of us Need
You Know Myself included so I think
that's that's the most important next
step is okay we have these six videos up
uh awesome now let's let's get you know
a weekly video going up and whatever it
takes to get that happening and then we
can come back and revisit strategy of
thumbnails and everything else but
you've got everything you need to start
to succeed we just need to get some
content going up to see me coaching
another entrepreneur one-on-one check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there